bilel konuşmacısı Yım O yüzden konuşmama
başlamadan önce herkesten ricam şöyle
bir enerjimizi toplayalım son bir
konuşmamız kaldı derin bir nefes alıp
verelim Sağ olsunlar beni çok güzel
tanıttılar havalı havalı unvanlarla E iş
deneyimlerim Öz Geçmişimle lütfen sıkıcı
kurumsal fotoğrafları unutalım şimdi
zaten görüyorsunuz kaykayın üzerine
dalga SF yapmay giden bir selam var şu
anda Gözlerinizin önünde
Ben bugün size Bütün bunlardan uzak
gerçek seneni anlatacağım gerçek senen
olma hikayemi anlatacağım ben hala
sizler gibi bir öğrenciyim arkadaşlar
kendimi hala bir öğrenci görüyorum çünkü
Bence öğrencilik gitmek bilmeyen bir
yolculuk değişen
evrilen kesişen bir yolculuk ve ben
farklı alanlarda disiplinlerde öğrenmeye
doyamayan ve bu öğrendiklerimi biri
[Müzik]
Gama
gü
bilü
kaar ben ne bölüm okuyacağım Hadi okudum
diyelim istediğim bölümü iş bulabilecek
miyim böyle birçok soru kafanızda
Öncelikle arkadaşlar Sakin olun Panik
Yok Çünkü yalnız değilsiniz hepimiz bu
yollardan geçtik benzer endişeleri
taşıdık Hatta ben bir gün kendime ben
gerçekten bu hayatta ne yapmak istiyorum
diy sorgularken bulduğum ki
ger
şanslısın çgün burki akam gince
sorulacaksınız
çoktan o zamanlar akı aldığım bir karer
danışım önerisi Annem
Ar
dedimi yaşan önce
neleri key alırdım ve saatler
sıkın Oyun oynuyordum ama Ne yapıyordum
tam
olarak çok enteresan bir cevap aldım ben
dergilerden gazetelerden parçalar kesip
birleştirmeyi çizmeyi boyamayı kolajlar
Yapı kendim için anlamlı şeyler üretmeyi
seviyormuş Bu arada kim bilir ne
çıkıyordu orta yani başkaları için
anlamlı olmadığı kesin ama benim için
çok anlamlıydı
Hatta sizinle çok özel bir şey
paylaşacağım belki ışıktan şu an çok
göremiyorsunuz ama bu benim ilk ş eserim
kağıtları kesmişim sonra bu kağıtlar bir
kartonla birleştirmiş ve
bildiğiniz dikip kendi ilk kitabı
basmışım arkadaşlar adı da arımaya bahar
geldi artık Nasıl bir hayal gücü varsa o
zamanlar şimdi bunu niye anlatıyorum
Çünkü bu cevabı duyunca Bu arada bu
soruyu kesinlikle sorun ebeveynlerin çok
enteresan cevaplar alabilirsiniz En
azından çok eğlenirsiniz Ondan eminim o
anda kafamda üniversite yıllarında
öğrenmiş olduğum medici etkisi aklıma
geldi Belki siz de duymuş da
okumuşsunuzdur mediciler ta 15 yüzyıl
florasında şairlerin
ressamların sanatçıların bilim
adamlarının bir araya gelmesini sağlayan
ve onlara alan açan Yani farklı
kültürlere disiplinlere alanlara alan
açıp kesişti Rönesansın patlamasına yani
rönesansa sebebiyet veren ailelerden
biri olarak görünür Şimdi bunu niye
anlatıyorum
[Müzik]
birb uygulayacağım uçacağım kaçacağım
kariyerimde olmac bu yol Kanter gözyaşı
ve çok çalışmak gerektiren bir yol Ama
ben şöyle birto kendim örnek aldım Vin
gibi
düşün gibi öğren iç dünyas hezar ama
bunu yaparken kendin ve dünya için
anlamlı bir şeyler yap ve bir etki yarat
şimdi Tek tek hepsine bakacağız Ama önce
Hezarfen kavramını size açıklamak
istiyorum Poly ya dazen bin fen olarak
adlandırılan birka alanda Engin bilgiye
sahip kişi demek şimon
vö zaman
birz Çünkü bir kimliği sade sanatçı
olarak görüyorsunuz Filo yaz Şair
mimardı birç anlamda kendini geliştirmiş
birdi bu
yıe ama 1 ve 7 prensibine değineceğim
birinci prensip prios sita İtalyanca
için kusura bakmayın merak demek ne
demek bu merak saf merak yani Hiçbir
ajandam olmadan Kim ne der Hani bazen
eminim sınıfta soru sormak istiyorsunuz
durur ama şimdi sorarsan ben rezil
olurum diyorsunuz ya da sorduktan sonra
tam birisi anlatırken Belki de onu tam
anlamıyla dinlemeyip kendiniz ne
diyeceğiniz planlıyorsunuz saf merak
işte Tam burada başlıyor o ne der
ara
ğünü
haber Twitter her gün bom
varlan ibar Günde 4 kitu arkadaşlar ve
haftada 85 saat çal biri ve kendis
sorulduğunda senin sırın nl bu kadar yaş
altında 4 milyar dolar şirk im
atabiliyorsun dendiğinde Kendisi şu şek
cevap veriyor
[Müzik]
Ben öğrenirken önce ağacın gövdesinden
başlayıp daha sonra dallarına daha sonra
yapraklarına gidiyor ama en önemlisi bir
alanda öğrendiğini diğer alana
aktarabiliyor yani
kesişti şimdi söz konusu öğrenmek
olduğunda burada bahsetmeden
geçemeyeceğim iki isim var yine bana
oldukça ilham veren şu anda adaşlar
görüyorsunuz yani Apple'ın kurucuları
Steve wni ve Steve Jobs görüyorsunuz
arkadaşlar yanda da bir alet var
bil olabilir
[Müzik]
yen falan değil sadece neleri
yapabileceklerini görmek veı
çağırıyorlar telefona Ve bunu yaparken
Beyaz Sarayın ünlü isi hener takit
ediyorlar bir de Alman aksanını
yapıyorlar bu hik Komik geliyor Bu arada
asında bu bir suç y ama bunu tabi
ücretsiz arama yapmak için yapmıyorlar
daha sonra ST Jobs Bu arada bunu Mutlaka
izleyin öyle güzel bir röportaj ki JS
miper kişiliğini göreceksiniz bu videoyu
iura Durdur i dedim burada anlatıyordum
hikayeyi oradan getirdim
size diyor ki Daha sonra kendi biyografi
yazarın mavi kutu olmasaydı bugün App
Olmazdı çünkü biz mavi kutuyu
yaptığımızda
lise ve bize bu dünyada her şey
yapabileceğimizi gösterdi bu mavi kutu
ve daha sonra gerisi söküldü
geldi
şimdi şu soruyu çok duyacaksınız
ama için çalışarak daha sonra Ailemiz
komitemiz için bu ülke için bu ülkeye
rağmen bu ülke için çalışarak düny için
olumlu etkiler yaratabilecek işler
yapabiliriz Ben Kendi hayatıma dönersem
biraz kendi geçmişime götüreceğim sizi
bu ünlü isimlerden sonra kendimi hep
doğru insanlarla hayatımda kesiştirme
çalıştım Çünkü şöyle bir söz vardır
Çevrenizdeki be kişinin ortalaması
kadarsınız diye bu söze gönülden
İnanırım
yıkes doğüm
bir eği öğet
göğs
kendisi Sen
ytç emi y ama Mus
an
Sürek olduğunu ve bana şöyle bir sözü
vardı Keskin sirk küpü zarar verir diye
iş hayatında o kariyer basamaklarını
tırmanırken Kalbimizdeki güzelliği
hiçbir zaman kaybetmememiz gerektiğini
öğrendim daha sonra Sri lanka'ya
gittiğimde dalga surfile tanıştım başta
Bir fotosunu paylaşmıştım dalga Surf
bana şunu öğretti siz ne yaparsanız
yapın Hayat size bambaşka bir yol
çizebilir O yüzden belirsizliği açık ol
çünkü Okyanus öyledir okyanusta her an
her dalga farklı şekildedir farklı hızda
gelir bir kesinlik
yoktur Ve daha da önemlisi zamanlamayı
öğrendim Bazen çok acele ediyoruz ya
doğru dalgayı beklemeyi öğrendim Çünkü
doğru dalgayı beklersen daha keyifli bir
sürüş yaparsın Biraz daha ileri
sarıyorum yoga hocalığı eğitimi alırken
Tamamen kendimi geliştirmek için aldım
aktif olarak hocalık yapmıyorum ama
kalbi şefkatle her şeye açık insanlarla
tanıştım ve Mesela bir poz var kafaüstü
duruş görüyorsunuz durur o poz bana en
başta çok korkunç gelirken daha sonra
Düşe Kalka Düşe Kalka yapa yapa o pozu
yapabildiğimi gördüm ve bu bana iş
hayatında da düştüğümde tekrardan
kalkmayı
öğretti daha sonra girişimcilik
dünyasına girdiğimde girişimcilikten
önce hatta e kariyerime pazarlamayla
başladım Daha sonra satışla devam ettim
Hani derler ya 5 sene sonra nerede
görüyorsunuz kendinizi görmüyorum Çünkü
hayat bana farklı bir yol çizdi
pazarlamacı odadan verken satışa Daha
sonra da pazarlamayla ve satışın tam
ortasına oturan Eee maalesef Türkçe
karşılığı yok o yüzden İngilizce sal
enablement dediğimiz bir mesleği
yaparken Buldum kendimi ve hayatın Hi
kalmadığım kadar aldım 5 sene önce
haberim bile yoktu böyle bir meslek
grubu olduğumdan ama hayat beni bir
şekilde buna kesiş şu anda 26 ülkenin
bütün satışçıların ve ülke müdürlerine
yol gösteriyorum Bir nevi eğitmenlik
yapıyorum ve hedeflerine ulaşmalarını
Sağlı yine girişimcilik dünyasına
girdiğimde son olarak doğru insanlarla
yani Türk mühendisleriyle
iyi Türk İş insanlarını bir araya
buluşturduğu ve doğru kültürü
yattığımızda Coğrafya kaderdir söylemini
tersine çevirebileceğimiz gördüm
Arkadaşlar bu topraklardan 25 ülkeye
Türk teknolojisi ihraç eden bir şirket
yarattık ve bugün Japonya'dan tutun
4 m 900
AIM
vış
toek çok çalışmamız lazım Eğer çok
çalışırsanız hayatınıza doğru insanları
sokarsanız İnanın bana uzaya roket bile
gönderebilirsiniz Arkadaşlar teşekkür
ederim